give me your thoughts on alc i know that
you you like to think about it
sometimes not really
unfortunately she injects herself into
the news
yeah i i basically view her as a kind of
um
kind of like a robespierre really i
think that she's very much like roshire
she's
she's a a politician or a political
actor and she's a radical a real radical
and she is uncompromising she's
she does not consider the republicans to
be moral agents
she views them in the same way that uh
the the hobbits view the agents of
sauron you know the the the naz girls
she views them like that
the fact that they exist is an
unfortunate necessity in the fact that
she has to deal with them
but she will attack them as viciously as
possible
at every opportunity that she gets i
mean the the perfect example recently
was her saying oh maybe the wall street
traders should be not stopping people
from training on their platforms
and ted cruz said i agree and she said
you nearly got me killed
it's like you should resign it's like
okay well that's not exactly
the spirit of cooperation is it aoc and
now today we've got the recent uh
i i'm a survivor of sexual assault the
way that the republicans are treating me
is basically the same way that i was
treated by the person who sexually
assaulted me
therefore the republicans are basically
gaslighting rapists and it's like right
okay this is not a good faith actor this
is someone who is
here to harm you they're here to
undermine you they're here to destroy
you they're get rid of you as much as
possible
and if you watch the um the sort of
speeches she gives on the interview she
gives
with friendly media people she knows her
inside the progressive club
she almost says exactly these things
she's like we've got to stop them we've
got to get rid of them they should
resign we need to replace them we need
to get rid of them and all sort of stuff
and so it's like she's not shy about
this and
she is the destructive radical communist
force that's entered into democratic
politics and is working its way
through the social uh mechanisms of
the american body politic damaging
people
who otherwise shouldn't think that they
would be damaged right the platformings
and things like this
aoc is the crest of that wave and
that's really bad this kind of bad will
this this this ill will that travels
through the political environment
is what's going to destroy the american
republic because the american republic
fundamentally is built on the idea of a
good will
that brings together a society from
which they can constitute a government
i mean it's literally in the declaration
of independence you know and it's based
on
locke's view of government and society
in the state of nature where men come
together voluntarily
to sacrifice some of their rights in
order to provide security and protection
for their property
and that will only hold as long as
you understand that there is a good will
in society and the government isn't
going to be used to persecute you
but the government is already being used
to persecute the mega folk
who happen to hold strongly to the
lockheed view
of the american republic and so on a
subconscious level
i don't doubt that there are many
american republicans out there thinking
my god the republic is absolutely over
because they're trying to use the
government to persecute us
and this this is the incredibly
negative effect that people like aoc and
the squad are having in american
politics
and uh and don't get me wrong the right
has their own versions of this
but the right the republicans keep out
the sort of richard spencer's and nick
fuentes's of the right the the you know
the
the belligerent and unforgiving culture
warriors
that would be on the right they don't
actually engage them you know they this
is this is why trump was such a surprise
because
he's like a halfway house between them
and the mainstream republicans you know
so in
an acceptable way politically um but
yeah so i
i'm i'm not very much a fan of aoc and
the way that she operates do you think
that she believes what she's saying
because when we saw kamala harris
last year during the democratic
primaries
and she essentially accused joe biden of
being a
sexual assaulting misogynist whatever it
was
and then when asked about it said
it was just a debate bro yeah yeah so i
don't believe that
kamala harris i like the fact that
someone who is such an evident sociopath
has made their way into the second
highest seat of power
in the free world is that
really scares me biden doesn't scare me
biden doesn't scare me
his um forgetfulness
worries me but he doesn't scare me
however
kamala harris really really does scare
me i'm
pretty good judge of people i've spent a
lot of time looking at people and
there is something incredibly wrong with
that woman
um i i think she's a corporate chill
i think she just uh is doing this for
her own enrichment and the enrichment of
her family and friends
but aoc i think probably is a true
believer i think that she
she knows that she's being insanely
hyperbolic when she's attacking
republicans
but i think she does on a genuine level
believe that they are bad people
and should be gotten rid of
[Music]
you